The final aspect of how the caches work,
concerns the write policy.
They're really two parts of it.
First is the so called allocate policy.
Which is about do we
insert into the cache?
Meaning allocate and entering
the cache for blocks that we write.
So we have a write miss.
The question is, does the block
get brought to the cache or not.
There are two types of caches.
The first type of cache is according
to this is a write-allocated cache.
It brings the block that
we write into the cache.
The second type does not.
So when we have a read miss.
The block is brought into the cache, but
if we have a write miss The block
is not brought into the caches.
Most cachestoday are write-allocate,
simply because there is some
locality between reads and writes.
Meaning if we write to something,
we are also likely to read it.
So write allocate helps us have read
hits, even if we have the write miss.
The other aspect of the Write Policy
is when we have a write,
do we write just to the cache or
also to the memory?
We can have a write-through cache,
which updates the memory immediately.
So when a write happens,
we write to the cache and
just propagate the write also to memory.
That's why it's called write-through,
because the write kind of
goes through the cache.
Or we can have a write-back cache,
where we only write to the cache, and
we write to memory only when
the block is replaced in the cache.
We cannot just discard
the block at this time,
because the memory does not have
the most recent version of the block, so
the memory has to be updated once
the block is no longer in the cache.
But as long as it's in the cache, we
will just keep writing to the cache, and
not keep memory up to date.
Write-through is a very
unpopular cache for
caches that send stuff
to memory directly.
We usually want to have a write-back
cache, because that way
writes which have a lot of locality will
update the cache possibly many times.
And only send a write to memory once,
once the blocked is replaced.
So we can have many writes.
And only one memory write for that.
That prevents the memory
from being overwhelmed with
the number of writes that we might have.
The results of some relationship
between this choice and this.
If you have a write-back cache, you want
to also have a write-allocate cache.
Because, you are saving writes to
memory, by writing only to the cache.
If you have a write miss, you want to
have future writes go to the cache so
you do write-allocate.